what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay too powerful for Marvel movies that
God butcher oh do we as soon as I
started this series I was like we have
to do a video on God butcher and people
knew we had to do a video on God butcher
there's no way you couldn't like there's
no way you couldn't do a video on God
butcher here's a funny thing though you
could make one hell of a movie out of at
dude I would love to see that for for
the god butcher dude I would look do
that you can make one hell of a movie
and it scared okay okay okay calm down
the god butcher alright so gore is like
one of the most interesting Thor
villains ever like like I don't actually
say he's probably the most interesting
Thor villain but he's more interesting
than like Loki or really like Man GOG
although man guy I would say is the most
dangerous because no one's ever
successfully defeated man GOG like man
GOG is the only villain that even Odin
is afraid of like Odin's terrified a man
GOG he's just he's like like it's crazy
that what was it the most recent story
that Jason arrant did in Thor
when Jane Foster lost the hammer man GOG
invades Asgard and they're just like
like Jane Foster's like well we have to
fight and Odin them or just like but why
though because like he's gonna kill us
so I mean this is Ragnarok please like
it's it was it was it was pretty messed
up because it was pretty awesome but uh
but no aside from man GOG I would say
good well man actually not that
interesting anyway so I would say Gore's
probably the most interesting for
villains so this all came out of Jason
eras initial run right and we have like
the whole Thor run in video form if you
guys want to go check it out but it's
the first run in Thor god of thunder
written by Jason Aaron drawn by Assad
Riddick it looks so amazing and and what
what is up happening is there's like
this unnamed planet out in the galaxy so
out in the universe somewhere and this
planet is insanely harsh to live on
right it almost never rains and in life
is just like it's a it's a constant
struggle and so there's this like alien
that's born on this world and his
parents died shortly after and so he's
basically raised by the tribe and then
eventually makes a life for himself
right like he finds a wife and he has a
child and someone and then like as
they're making their their journey to
like the next place where they can find
some places you know some some measure
of refuge like food water different
things like that his wife and child died
and it's crazy because the leader of the
tribe is more or less like a priest and
and so he's just like well you know the
gods have this plan for us you know and
it's settled you know God has a plan so
on so and the result is like in in the
face of all this scores like know if the
gods are real they've abandoned us and I
don't even believe they exist in the
first place
and so because he denies the existence
of the various gods that his people
believe him he's like excommunicated
from his tribe well eventually what
happens
is the necro sword like like God who is
it the first oh no the original the
original sir not the original sir but
the original sibian guy anyway he and
somebody else are fighting each other
and they fall down to the planet when
they're both dead and gore discovers
like the all-black necro sword which is
like the sword of death and so gore goes
on like this crusade because he's fine
he's like he's like these gods deserve
to die they died of their own volition I
will kill the rest and so like he takes
the all-black necro sword and goes on
like this crusade across the across like
the universe killing every God he finds
every planets God like he goes through
and kills kills almost all of them
except for like maybe a couple of them
but eventually he makes his way to earth
now when he makes his way to earth it
happens something like like a thousand
years ago or three thousand years ago or
something on those lines but it happens
in the past and Thor at that point in
time was still like relatively young and
brash and so I want to say that the way
it played out was Thor discovered the
body of a God from the Americas that
washed up on the rocks up somewhere and
then he was just kind of like well
that's crazy and then he left and then
eventually he discovers what are
basically like Russian gods and he
finally and he realizes like they've all
been huh they didn't die of natural
causes like they're all just like
hanging on meat hooks and he's like what
in the hell happened here like who
killed all these guys because they were
like warrior gods right and so that's
that's one like gore makes his
appearance and like he faces off against
Thor and beats the hell out of them do
gore absolutely thrashes Thor it's not
even it's not even a contest I mean he
just he wears him out and it's what did
is one of the funniest things ever he
torches him for like for like a week or
like like months or something like that
oh he tortures him for like days on and
trying to get information and Thor just
doesn't relent so gordas kind of leaves
him and then Thor basically recovers the
two of them fight again and then Gore is
thought to have been defeated and
thought to have been killed so Thor says
okay whatever and then walks away come
to find out Gore never died and over the
course of the next however many years
running up until the present day Gore
continued his campaign wiping out like
gods of war and gods of like conflict
and gods of love and gods of hate all
these different gods that were out there
like he was going through and just like
wiping them all out killing killing all
of them everywhere he found and so
modern-day Thor runs into Gore again
he's like I remember you from a thousand
years ago and he's just like how are you
still alive and Gore's like don't worry
about that because but Gore's been
getting stronger like like the longer he
used the necro sword and the more gods
he killed the stronger he got and so by
this point he's vert like he's virtually
unchallenged like like Thor doesn't
really stand a chance against him and so
ultimately the battle ends are taking
place in the future
and what is up happening is you end up
having past or present Thor and future
Thor all facing off against Gore at the
same time and they all still get rekt
like it's dudas it's it's insane Gore
defeats three generations of Thor all at
the same time and you end up finding out
that what Gore had been planning was to
create something called the god bomb
right the idea was that he was gonna
take he was gonna create this massive
bomb and he was gonna drop it off in the
timestream in a literal time stream and
he was gonna detonate it and when it did
it would send shockwaves throughout the
past the present in the future and he
would annihilate all gods and he just
hasn't found because you got remember
with Gore like running around and
killing all these gods word had reached
the ears of various people and they just
when they do this when to Heidi I'm
absolutely what it was we were just like
free for your lives like if they all
just ran in every conceivable direction
scattered to the winds and just went
into hiding and so he's like those that
I haven't found I'll kill them this way
and so what it is a like what what is up
happening is it ends up taking I think
modern-day Thor wielding two hammers and
possessed by the all-black necro sort to
defeat Gore it's that dude he looks so
awesome to Gordon and like Gordon show
them a picture that gorgeous minor chord
and show them a picture of what Thor
looks like wielding two hammers in the
all-black neck restored he's like he
likes smashes the hammers together dude
it's like the coolest thing ever I was
dude I was reading that story almost
ripping through that story man like I
got a hole in that thing I was like man
this beast and I was always reading
through the stories tearing it up now I
was like man I was like dude Jason
arrant saw a man do Jason air man he
smashed it right from the word go D
right out of the gate he had that here
to go house like a man - Jason Aaron man
a man whose man he means business man
and so it was he was one of the coolest
things I've ever seen but I'm just
saying you cannot have I mean you could
do Gore and in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe there probably is you're
talking about a character that was
powerful enough to like single-handedly
crush three versions of Thor all at the
same time what's the Incredible Hulk
gonna do what's Iron Man gonna do or
like Black Widow or like Hawkeye who's
gonna be Ronan Avengers for don't know
why you wouldn't be all know anybody who
doesn't believe he would be of course it
can be running why would he be running
in Avengers 4 we need Ronan by God and
we're gonna get him so so like I mean
what are any of these guys gonna do it
would take someone like Hyperion and
even then there probably would like even
then it probably wouldn't work like you
would you would take the Incredible Hulk
Thor and Hyperion in order to pull it
off if we're not talking about the
all-black necro sword but if we're
talking about Gore wielding the
all-black necro sword full power no no
no it would be it'd be an absolute
bloodbath but it could potentially be a
Gore kills the Marvel Universe
to be one of the coolest things do they
be one of the most most beast things to
play out I mean you're talking about a
guy that lives to destroy things that
lives to like wipe out gods as this s
all Gor wants to do is wipe out God's
everywhere he finds it he'll kill you if
you get in the way I mean if you're like
Captain America and you're like oh yeah
freedom then and then you get in the way
and so on so I'm gonna throw a little
shield hey if you're if you're talking
about like so any like that he's like
okay well then fine like I'll kill you
and then I'll take your shield and I'll
turn it into like the all-black necro
shield and then I'll have a sword in the
shield and it'll be awesome like like
the Incredible Hulk
probably not I mean okay it depends
because the Incredible Hulk is so
finicky right because he has like
infinite strength like the anger he gets
a stronger you so if the fight went on
long enough
yes the Incredible Hulk would win but in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe like all
the characters across the MCU are by and
large like much weaker than their comic
book versions and so the Incredible Hulk
if you took Gore from the comic books
directly into the movies and didn't
reduce his power then no love The
Incredible Hulk it's like he would get
decimated like right off the bat I went
dude if you guys thought what Thanos did
was Batman Lords hey y'all if y'all
thought what Thanos did was bad all
right if you guys thought Santos
wrecking wrecking the Hulk like that in
infinity war was bad yeah I got nothing
on Gore do this it's I mean that like
dance is more powerful than forth but
I'm just saying like not even in hell
would you see a massacre like what you
would see if Gore showed up in the MCU
and just started laying waste to all the
earth superheroes gonna be absolute
pandemonium oh my god would be absolute
pandemonium ajan that could you remember
we're here live in New York where some
being who looks really really weird he
looks like Voldemort from the Harry
Potter books has somehow managed to make
his way into the into the city of
Manhattan and he's killing everyone you
know it's like yeah man he's like my
name is Gore I want to imagine what he
would sound like right like I am cool
like it couldn't be like super deep like
he would have to be it couldn't be like
fantasy Thanos is like the least
intimidating sounding villain ever
Josh Brolin love you man you're a great
actor no country for old man's like my
top three favorite films of all time but
but like sales voice need to be like
deeper you know like like almost unlike
like inhumanly deep you know like oh no
I'm gonna wipe out half the life in the
universe which won't actually do
anything because in the other half of
the life the universe will recover and
then have more kids and then we'll be
right back where we started again like
like you know that's that's fine
but his voice needs to be like deeper
like more hardcore like intense but like
door needs to be just like menacing I
mean just like menace
singing as hell right worse it's like if
death was talking to me right now it
would sound like him but he s he s to be
like the thee has to be the living
embodiment of death right like Robert
Oppenheimer you know I am become death
the destroyer of worlds
but he has to be like Mike sound like
that guy and it's just like it's like
I'm just saying man I'm just I'm just
saying go where the god butcher would be
amazing to see in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but he's just too powerful they
have to tone him down and make him like
a that could be an Avengers movie in and
of itself like pick the movie up and
like in the first 20 minutes it's like a
thousand years ago and like Thor fights
core and just gets absolutely decimated
and like Thor just forgot about it
because he thought that Gore was dead
and then Gore returns and forces select
they're like oh my god Thor this is your
villain right he's like yes brother oh
yes rabbit this is my this is my villain
you know and look what do we do is like
we do nothing we die because he's way
too powerful for us like I want to see
that I want to see that circumstance
unfold the rabbit is right we are doomed
to die so everyone bend over and kiss yo
asses goodbye I think it'd be amazing to
see but let me know what you guys think
down in the comment section if you guys
are new here - how much explain make
sure you all hit the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]